Joe Biden's win may be a double-edged sword for teachers unions.
Teachers unions worked hard to elect Biden, a long time ally.
And public support for teachers is high.
Many parents express a new found appreciation
for just how exhausting the job can be.
Yet, as school systems around the country shut their doors,
or delay reopening despite mounting evidence that in-person learning can be done safely,
parents' patience is wearing thin.
Until now, President Trump's reckless calls for schools to open immediately
have allowed unions to portray their resistance to reopening
as the "responsible" position.
With Trump gone, that changes.
If Biden is wearing a mask and pushing for more school funds,
It'll be tough for unions to insist that reopening is just a Trumpian rush
back to business as usual.
Under President Biden, unions will face a clear choice:
Help lead on responsibly reopening schools,
or risk stoking concerns that they're more focused on member convenience
than student wellbeing.
Their choice will be telling.
Do you think teachers and schools have risen to the challenge of COVID?
Let us know in our poll.
Also, let us know what other topics you'd like our scholars to cover in 60 seconds
And be sure to like and subscribe for more research and videos from AEI.